a Russian court has rejected an appeal
by The Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gershowitz he's being held in pre-trial
detention in Russia and denies the
charges that happened in the last few
moments our International correspondent
John Sparks joins me now uh John this is
a blow for him and his legal team
clearly
uh yes uh blow a disappointment but not
unexpected
um I I don't think that there was really
any realistic chance that uh that kovich
would get the equivalent of bail in this
situation the court has said that he
will be held until May 29th on Espionage
Espionage charges or spying
um
but I think that the trial is highly
likely to go ahead he's currently been
held in a notorious Russian prison
called lefortovo it's where the the
Russian government the Soviets before
them have held political prisoners
essentially trying to get bail to be
held outside of a a present-like that
leading up to the trial but this appeal
where we have seen him for the first
time this this case his appearance in
Moscow City Court was really about his
pre-trial detention it wasn't about the
substance of those charges the Russians
say that he was caught red-handed trying
to obtain classified material about an
arms Factory in your Catherine Berg
that's about 2 000 miles 2000 kilometers
sorry east of Moscow in Siberia the
Americans have responded at saying that
his detention is totally illegal those
are the words of the U.S President Joe
Biden and their state department their
foreign office said that this is a
political case it's um the charges are
bogus so the Americans have been very
strong on that and I should say that the
American ambassador Lynn Tracy was
actually in court this morning at
watching this appearance where
gershkovich appeared in this sort of
cabinet this glassed this glass cabinet
the media were allowed in to take
pictures of him as well that's the first
time that he has been seen since the end
of March the Russian foreign ministry
didn't like the fact that the American
ambassador
was there watching proceedings and they
have complained I understand
they have complained accusing the
Americans and the British and the
Canadians of gross interference in the
Russian legal process and their
diplomatic Representatives have been
summoned we understand to the Russian
foreign Ministries buildings in Moscow
and I should say that they also attended
the
Vladimir Cara Mirza sentencing yesterday
at the British Ambassador was there at
the American Lynn Tracy the Ambassador
they were there as well so the Russians
do not like the fact that diplomats
Western diplomats are turning up at
these at these trials they see that as
interference the media were let in
briefly to take pictures as we can see
of gershkovic
he looked pretty looked pretty calm he
has spoken to the U.S ambassador
yesterday she said that he was
relatively healthy and relatively good
spirits he's also written he's written
he's been able to write to his parents
in the states that he was able to get
some exercise and was eating properly he
looked pretty calm but the situation is
very serious and I don't think there is
any real Prospect of the Russian
authorities letting out letting him out
anytime soon
you can tell you John we can see live
pictures from outside the court outside
Moscow City Court these are the lawyers
speaking uh listen Maybe in Russia but
let's listen in
oh we don't have any sound on that I'm
afraid I can't bring you any sound on
that
um but but John just uh just keep
telling us more about this situation I
mean in terms of how unprecedented it is
it's such a long time since it's a
foreign journalist especially American
journalist and one of a sort of
accredited mainstream media has been
held like this in Russia isn't it
yeah that's right I mean I I don't think
that we have seen the arrest of an
American or any Western journalist like
this in Russia since really the end of
the Cold War I think it is it is
unprecedented obviously the experience
for independent journalists in Russia is
very different you see the press
conference there held by the law is
breaking up but it is an unprecedented
situation and I think people will see
parallels here between the the closing
of the the public space the increase in
repression in Russia that now that
journalists are facing including
International journalists as we can see
here Civil Society other people who are
minded
to criticize the Russian government and
the invasion of Ukraine that's what we
saw with Vladimir caramoza yesterday the
Russian British national who was
sentenced to up to 25 years by the by
the Russian court for essentially
speaking his own mind about Vladimir
Putin and the invasion of uh Ukraine I
think the case here with gershkovich
has its own subtleties and I think a lot
of people in Russia and outside
think that what the Russians may be
doing here is preparing this case
preparing gershkovic for a prisoner swap
there are Russians in American prisons
that the Russians would like to get back
they may be looking at this as a need
very practically as a means to get
Russians held in American prisons back
we saw that happen in December an
American basketball player called
Brittany Greiner was swapped for a
Russian called Victor belt he's a
notorious arms Trader he was arrested in
in Thailand some years ago and
extradited to the United States those
two were swapped in December and this
may be part of the thinking on behalf of
the security service the sfb and the
Russian authorities that they use
gershkovic Ervin groshkovic he's a 31
year old he's a relatively young
journalist been working for the Wall
Street Journal
so they use him this way to swap him for
somebody now in a American jail
certainly possible